明明知道自己有这方面的携带，
有这方面的疾病，
不告诉对方生孩子，
抱着一种侥幸的心理去赌自己的运气，
我觉得这种人的话都存在，
生出孩子来多不负责任，
孩子多遭罪。
我老公要不要分手？
我们是在2023年下半年结婚了，
我父母呢，
乡镇的做小生意的，
是隔壁市的市职事业编，
我老公呢，
他的父母是乡镇的在边教师，
他是乡镇的事业编，
他的家乡和我的家乡，
还有我现在的工作是在三个地方编剧，
大概70km的样子，
我老公他的工作地方是在我家乡镇的，
当时我们就是在那边认识的，
后来我又考到隔壁市的市值事业编，
我现在整体工资待遇大概一年就是12万，
我老公呢，
大概是七八万块钱，
现在所遇到的情况这几个这是点让我很困扰，
就是第一个我们结婚以后大概一年的样子，
我老公查出来有遗传性的疾病，
他是性脊柱炎，
但是是早期，
可能有遗传风险，
是以后孩子都有影响。
第二个他爸爸有一件事情说就让我很不舒服，
去年九月份的时候，
他父亲就有一次喝多酒了，
把我和我老公喊到他的房间去了，
我们两个20多分钟，
是我老公的不好，
都是我撺掇的，
都是我父母他们撺掇的，
说我家里面结婚的时候对我和我那里面说从老到。
话都没有看得上的，
我就觉得他们可能有点看不起我，
他们平常对我也挺好的，
就是我周六周日回去也不让我做家务，
有时候也给我包饺子。
第3个事情，
因为我们是异地，
我对象是在我家乡那边的事业编，
我呢是在隔壁市的事业编，
结婚之前我们就想着考到我对象他们家那边的编制，
但是呢，
已经是考第三次了，
今年也不知道能不能考上，
一直都在学习，
那几年也不敢玩全感是就是看不到镜头，
都不知道该怎么办。
第4点就是我对象他在备考的时候情绪也比较压抑，
今年过年的时候，
我们大年初五的时候去了我叔叔家里面，
8点半才到，
然后大概一点半的时候，
我对象他就突然离席了，
跟长辈静酒的时候发现找不到孩子，
就出去找他，
他特别生气，
他的意思是当会他中午休息，
当我他下午学习等，
我怕特别扎心，
等我回到那个饭桌上，
我就说他打电话了，
有事嘛，
他们就说等他打完电话让他过来就一起聊聊天，
平常跟长辈见的很少，
我就喊我跟他，
他就特别生气，
还是去敬酒了，
然后他敬完酒以后说去给小辈敬酒的时候都恨得牙痒痒，
但一瞬间就是我心特别冷，
到现在我对他态度也不是很好，
他有可能是就是想跟我缓和关系，
跟我开玩笑，
但是我一点都开心不起来了，
他现在考完试也结束了，
我就特别想离婚，
我不知道该怎么抉择，
他的那个遗传的概率有多大呀，
医生就是说。
那个第二期阳性就是，
呃，
有遗传的概率，
遗传以后发病还有一定的概率，
可能说整体在20%的样子吧，
这概率挺大的了，
那我再讲一下，
他们每次周六周日到他们家，
不用我做家务，
也不喜欢我干活什么的，
这样我对象平常对我那也挺好的吧，
做家做家务呢，
帮我分开，
我就是洗衣服或者是切菜洗菜，
他们就是帮我，
有没有这种可能性，
就是通过做试管婴儿可以排除这种遗传性呢，
我上网搜了一下，
试管婴儿虽然说能够排除那个第二期阳性那个基因，
但是的话不排除这个发病的可能，
没有什么特别直接的效果，
我设身处地的想一象啊，
因为我现在自己有孩子，
我想如果有20%的可能会让我的孩子得这种病的话，
我能不能接纳，
我可能接纳不了，
因为他太痛苦，
这个病很痛苦的，
是的，
发病的时候就晚上根本就没法入睡，
那站起来好一电话，
他根本没法睡觉，
对，
太折磨人了，
如我因为我的一个选择，
让我的孩子去经历这些，
我会很恨我自己，
我觉得没有一个男人值得我冒这么大的风险去让我的孩子遭受这些，
就有的时候你像当妈的是什么心情啊，
哪怕你和我自己遭受这种，
我都不愿意他走，
我可以选择的话，
我们再在一起，
其他。
就姐结婚之前他也没这个病，
结婚以后才查出来这个病，
你说我俩就丁克那另当别论啊，
我之前跟他们提过，
就是跟我对象提过，
要不就是丁克，
我也愿意陪他这样一辈子，
但是他不同意，
他家就他一个儿子，
他想至少也要有一个孩子，
他父亲就是还老是催催着生孩子，
他父亲明知道他自己儿子有这个问题，
现在还在打那个商务之计，
但是还一直催生孩子，
今年过年的时候刚到家，
他父亲就把他喊到那个屋里面，
就说什么今年过年没有抱上孙子，
很没有面子，
让他都没有办法回老家，
怎么样的让人生气这样的，
他父母虽然知道他有这个病，
但是这个嘴上都不承认，
都觉得他没有事。
我那天看到有一对姐妹，
她们俩就是生活在一起，
就是因为他们的父亲隐瞒了这种基因性的疾病，
然后呢，
先是妹妹发病，
不能控制自己的身体，
走着走着就走下去了，
肌肉型的那个疾病，
后来她姐姐也发病了，
明明知道自己有这方面的携带，
有这方面的疾病，
不告诉对方生孩子，
抱着一种侥幸的心理去赌自己的运气，
我觉得这种人的话都生出孩子来多不负责任，
孩子多遭罪。
现在我也不知道该怎么跟他提，
他对我跟他也挺照顾的，
如果跟他提离婚的话，
我也不知道财产怎么分配，
如果你现在没想好，
就做。
避孕措施，
你跟他过得幸福，
幸福一年算一年，
但不生孩子，
其实还有一个问题，
就是比较隐私，
我不知道该不该这样讲，
我之前也没有那的经验嘛，
我们也没成功，
你结婚多久了，
两年多了，
两年多都没成功，
这不是经验的问题，
应该也不是说他的问题，
他也正常，
就是我俩就是好像就不太懂，
你俩都没谈过恋爱，
以前我之前也比较保守，
然后也没有经验，
我跟你说这事儿啊，
他是有问题的，
他问题在于什么，
就他再不懂，
再不懂他也看出啊，
他再不懂再不懂他不可能纯洁的像白纸一样，
这实不看他有问题的啊，
这两年就是一直都在考试，
有时候去他家那边也没那个现趣，
也不方便，
到现在这样的情况，
他是有问题的啊，
你赶紧分了吧，
但这结婚都两年多了，
他们家给了166000的彩礼，
就给了3万多的餐金，
要怎么退了？
如果按照法律来说的话，
第一，
你们确实是在一起结婚了，
生活了两年，
第二，
你没有什么过错，
你又没托人，
你又没干什么别的，
第三，
确实他自己身体有问题，
第4，
你们的这个生活也没有正常的那个什么，
在这种情况下几乎退的很少，
我不知道干嘛被他出，
如果你觉得人家人也不错，
你觉得你提分开对他心有所愧，
我觉得这一部分也是可以的，
我们结婚之后有是要大了。
几万块钱，
他可能是只有我攒了七八万块钱，
可是就是基本上有十几万，
主要还是我这边攒下来的，
因是他工资比较低，
又要那个治病什么的，
该这么跟他分了，
凭良心嘛，
因为他不是婚前隐瞒，
他也挺可怜的嘛，
他也是婚后才知道他得了这个疾病嘛，
他也没有做什么对不起你的事情嘛，
我觉得这个就是凭良心了，
正常按法律来说的话，
一人一半，
你要觉得你也对不住他的人候，
你多给他分一点，
我也就是在网上问，
大概说给他分10万块钱，
按照法律来说，
分10万块钱是合理的，
如果说想快速结束的话，
打16万六给他，
对，
就是现金什么的，
我来收不了，
这样合适吗？
不合适，
我觉得退太多了啊，
我就怕，
怕他到时候全家不愿意，
就一直这样，
不知道他自己愿意的话，
那就咱就摊开来说了，
首先第1点我没有做错什么事情，
我没有偷人，
我没有做错什么，
我该做的妻子在履行的义务，
我都愿意履行，
但是到目前为止，
他确实就不行了，
我感觉啊，
退个六万八万的就可以了，
我自己的感觉是这样的，
因为毕竟其实你没做错什么事情吗？
担心一要不要退掉，
担心这个事情啊，
咋说呢，
就都带了，
都已经旧了，
你退他还有什么用呢，
怎么着呢，
再去卖，
再去折价，
我我不知道这个三星它的那个婚后增值价值要不要跟他分一个，
没必要，
因为三星这个东西的话，
就是一种携带嘛，
就是个人物品。
啊，
没必要了啊，
你妈了，
他他是先能分款，
但是存款的话各挣各彩礼钱，
退一部分存款的话各挣各的，
各挣各的是什么意思呢？
就是该怎么分怎么分，
从法律来说的话，
就一人一半，
从那个情理来说的话，
就是挣得多的多分点，
挣的少的少分点，
行，
如果跟他提的话，
我直接先提，
提多少呢？
我先提个时候，
他可能会提个高一点的，
我觉得这个事儿你应该问他，
你应该让他来说，
你觉得这事儿我深度考虑过了，
我们两个人在一起生活了两年多，
我们夫妻生活这方面你也是心里清楚的，
也不是长久之计。
再有一个就是我也不想冒这个风险，
以后生孩子如果20%要遗传这个疾病的话，
孩子也遭罪，
也希望你能理解，
然后就让他说，
这样说会不会对他比较残忍，
在这种情况下坦诚，
你说不说她也知道你是因为他的病啊，
快的谢谢，
好再见啊，
拜拜，
记得点赞关注哦。